Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to take a look at some tips and tricks and
plugins when it comes to working with Unreal. So let's get started. So one of the things
you do need or several things I should say, you do need to look out for is one is glowing
objects that can give off light with Lumen but can create artifacts if the object is
too small. So keep in mind your size and scale. Moving glowing items can be trouble
also. You'll see in the example here, I have a moving texture that has a glowing material
in there. The problem with that is you can't get noise on that. So just be aware of size
scale and exactly how fast that movement might be merged nanite objects. Objects do
not work well with nanite processes as a calculation can be a double workload. So you want to
make sure that you're not merging nanited objects or converting merged objects which
came in nanited into a new nanited object. That is a bit more than Unreal really needs.
And you can keep those separate if you need to. Not a problem. Nanite can handle
them pretty well. But again, use everything in moderation, only place it in your world
as needed. So nanite objects don't work well with spline shapes. By default, construction
scripts with splines can give visual display issues. So make sure you adjust if you do
use them in a construction scenario, like I showed you earlier on in the videos, you
adjust your max edge length factor and make it so that the best possible silhouette
is being displayed by that object in that blueprint construction script. Using hardware
ray tracing to support Lumen is the best approach for performance and helps with intersection
geo calculations. Ambient occlusion static fraction, if turned off in the project settings
is not supported by some quixel materials. And AO in the material will need to be edited
to avoid deep black shadows. So older versions of quixel with older materials set in, if
you decide to turn that off, as some of our recommendations say, to get the best possible
results from your Lumen, you may run into deep dark shadows, and you'll have to go
into the parent material and adjust the AO so that it is not giving you these deep
shadows and working correctly. Here are some plugins that you can look at. And you definitely
can use them for your scene. Now, not all of them may be necessary, but they're
there to be able to help you as you go. You'll see there's volume metrics, as well
as PCG, which we talked about. Substance painter plugin is available for those that
may not be aware of it. Niagara fluids, if you do need that in your scene, there's
an M5 VX volume 2, fire and flames with Niagara. It's free and works pretty well.
And you have a temperate vegetation if you want to try that out. But we do have
new vegetation coming down the pipe that is going to be more voxel based and can
be really helpful. So be ready for that in the next coming builds. Common UI,
Interactive World is free. We have a limbic importer, we have groom and
etc. If needed. Datasmith, if you're using 3D Studio Max, can be super
helpful. And all KS plugins, of course, as you need. So be aware of what is
experimental and what isn't experimental. So you don't want to ship
necessarily with experimental features, because there are a few things such as
in some of the water features, as well as in such as some of the Datasmith.
And you'll find them in a few items that we have that I've pointed out
earlier, you such as Megalites. So just tread with caution and try things
out as you go.